à sony blatter commence qu'il s'occupe
pour se distraire elle manque des choses
c'est à dire que des statues à mon âge
est hélas pas tellement si le dimanche
en sorte que sa partie de cartes
[Musique]
les copains il ne faut rien exagérer
certains s'accommodent mal de rester
toute leur vie la moitié qui n'a pas
trouvé l'autre mais le célibat n'est pas
une maladie honteuse ceux qui pour des
raisons personnelles ou circonstancielle
non pas qu'on volé cherche dans l'amitié
une compensation qui n'est qu'un
palliatif
le vrai problème et sociale si les
agriculteurs n'assurent pas leur
descendance il y aura au moins deux
inconvénients sérieux la désertification
de la campagne s'accentuera les petites
et moyennes exploitations auront
tendance à disparaître
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
est ce qu'ils vendent pas que de figure
si qui veulent rester à la campagne il y
en a plus il faut pas chercher à peine
on n'en reste pas là campagne c'est
qu'il faut tailler à terre puis alors
finalement support facile de se marier
la campagne a pas de calais et avait le
panier c'est la fille et vienne elle est
intéressée opération travers le jeu qui
se marier positivement sa mère dès que
ça allait aller au marché amm aléas à
l'usiné elle dit notamment les jeunes
moi je vois pas la possibilité
est-ce que c'est pas aussi parce que les
intérieurs ne sont pas toujours assez
confortable pour une femme c'est à dire
que voilà il faudrait revoir leur chemin
on peut isoler moi je suis assez isolé
je maison est à 6 km du premier village
alors à manger un moyen de locomotion et
puis que j'ai un métier que je peux
faire dans ce petit village n'est pas
évident c'est difficile donc je vais
essayer de trouver quelque chose à faire
la maison tous les jeunes agriculteurs
vous avez installé les intérieurs de vos
maisons vous avez à peu près tout le
confort moderne maintenant alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont donc je pense que
c'est plutôt la liberté c'est surtout ça
lorsque ici avec les bêtes on est pris
dimanche et semaine quoi faire pareil
alors c'est plutôt sage pas les jeunes
filles aimeraient avoir le week-end
aimerait avoir la possibilité de partir
le samedi de rentrée le lundi comme
fondées majorité jeune fille en vie et
je pense que les garçons resterait
facilement se trouver à s'occuper
on ne serait ce que en fait d'abord leur
travail professionnel et ensuite avoir
des loisirs alors que les otages
ils sont beaucoup plus difficiles dans
nos campagnes voilà pourquoi les jeunes
filles préfèrent rencontre et peut-être
des jeunes jambes de la ville et ne pas
se marier ici alors il ya beaucoup de
garçons qui s'arrondit s'expatrient
celles qui restent ont choisi
délibérément la vie à la ferme même si
elles ont parfois tenté à la ville une
expérience décevante
je suis né à la campagne par un
agriculteur et je suis parti à 18 ans
travailler en ville et la vie en ville
ne vous a pas séduit aussi une période
mais je suis resté deux ans et puis je
suis revenu d'exploitation à nouveau et
je suis un nouveau reparti parce que
alors tu es obligé de partir quand mon
frère
reprenez le potassium mois et toujours
partir en ville dans votre vie de femme
à la campagne est ce qu'elle n'est pas
quand même un peu trop solitaire par
rapport justement ce que vous avez connu
non pas du tout absolument pas du tout
parce que le temps la campagne est
tellement diversifiée moi ça me remplit
mi-journée puis j'aime beaucoup les
bêtes je n'y a pas de travaux ingrats
aussi parce que par exemple on va chez
pas à nettoyer les bêtes c'est plutôt
agréable sais je sais pas mais même
quand il fait très chaud non plus c'est
pas très agréable dans le froid est-ce
qu'il n'ya pas aussi le fait que la
campagne a eu longtemps mauvaise
réputation les odeurs le fumier puis des
intérieurs mal à ranger et ça je le
pense parce qu'un principe à la campagne
il le fallait beaucoup se moderniser le
matériel alors y en a beaucoup qui
partait sur le matériel avant d'avancer
des intérieurs une répartition du budget
ah oui c'est au tour de nos matériels
pour s'équiper droit manque de personnel
en était ouvrier s'équiper en matériel
alors fait passer le matériel le premier
la place à l'intérieur je crois que je
suis revenu à la campagne par peut-être
un besoin de se retrouver dans la nature
un peu de chercher un peu plus loin mais
en fait on n'a pas le temps on
s'aperçoit quand on y est qu' on est on
est pris quoi est ce qu'une femme a le
temps de s'ennuyer à la campagne au nom
non au contraire je crois qu'on en
profite plus assez pour qu'il accepte de
vivre dans cette solitude faut quand
même qu'elle est certaine force de
caractère et je crois que c'est
essentiel d'ailleurs il ya beaucoup de
deux jeunes femmes comme ça que je
connais qui font plus ou moins des
dépressions ça c'est en arrivant la
dépression peut-être que justement la
nature finit par toujours donné parce
que la nature vous aident en fait on
finit par toujours retomber sur ses
pieds
j'ai pas votre mari élève des moutons si
participer pas aux travaux de la ferme
ou très peu au moment des foins oui vous
faites des fois ah oui j'aime bien parce
que je sens l'odeur très agréable c'est
agréable c'est la police et donné le
signalement très différente de victoire
oui mais je conduis le tracteur des
choses comme ça quoi ça n'a pas de sens
finges est quand même pour certaines
choses même au moment de l'agnelage
j'aime beaucoup me promener aller voir
la nuit il faut faire des tournées
toutes les nuits et temps en temps j'y
vais certainement à 3 heures du matin
des choses comme ça il faut couper la
nuit
peut-on imaginer que le niveau
intellectuel ou social interviennent et
que la femme mieux armée sur le plan
intellectuel s'adapte mieux à la
campagne la famille vous êtes bien
adoptés et bien avant avant le mariage
ils ont c'était c'était la ligue contre
oui et puis maintenant on suit là on
m'accepte côté des gens du village les
gens du village
on était au début très femme oui réservé
et puis même un peu claude greff enfin
la parisienne c'était la parisienne
qu'est ce que le sucre la chandeleur
l'attendait au tournant
et puis maintenant je me sens à l'aise
et je me sens bien avec que je pense que
c'est encore autre chose qu il gâte le
jeune fille se retournait allons à
l'école alors les mamans vous êtes août
qu'elle soit acheter tes tristes ou bien
voir ingénieurs docteurs ou enfin à
l'école et rentrer à la maison ne l'a
même pas le col est fiché qui a dit ceci
c'est la caricature une image d'un monde
révolu dont on trouve parfois un reflet
fugitif et dont seuls les poètes
regretteront la disparition avait trouvé
des correspondantes en mai corrézien
mais là où c'était un échec complet
d'épaisseur faire aucun mariage
vous êtes célibataire ça vous pèse
parfois certainement pour le moment je
m'en aperçois pas trop peut-être laissé
quelques années il ya double problème la
vie quotidienne et puis la succession
voilà ma personne pour pendant cette
question je vais travailler pour qui
tant que les parents sont là les parents
sont âgés mais la mère de famille est là
c'est ali s'occupe de l'intérieur le
célibataire n'est plus seul mais ses
parents vieillissent et disparaissent
les célibataires se trouve tout seul
j'ai actuellement quelques célibataires
qui sont seuls et bien comme vous savez
l'homme n'est pas fait pour vivre seul
et je ne le regrette pas
on est bien comme ça on est libre et
j'en profite vous savez maintenant vous
n'avez jamais voulu vous marier je suis
bien tranquille comme ça vous n'avez
jamais eu envie de marquer mais sa passe
est célibataire lorsqu'il est seul à
tendance est évidemment à faire une
cuisine légère est à prendre comme
nourriture principale du pain du vin et
du fromage l'a peut-être un budget un
petit un petit peu du vin ce qui n'est
pas une mare commandés on dit que
l'oisiveté n'est pas bonne c'est bien
évident est bon un célibataire qui tout
seul dans une ferme enfin robin mans est
célibataire que nous avons sur la
commune commence à prendre un certain
âge
ça pose un certain nombre de difficultés
ne serait ce que sur le plan matériel et
humain
donc il faut considérer les choses
telles qu'elles sont c'est-à-dire que
célibataire qui reste dans sa ferme qui
peut pas se marier
eh bien disons que je peux dire c'est un
sous développés sur le plan humain et
moral mais enfin il est dans un état
c'est dément d'intériorité par rapport
au reste de la population
on l'a constaté autre chose c'est que
dans un village comme ça robert il y
avait un esprit de camaraderie et
d'amitié formidable oui heureusement le
ce côté là parce qu'entre oise et on
s'entend très bien voir si on a besoin
d'un coup de mer les là alors là ça a
beaucoup quoi ça remonte un peu le moral
et le soir quand couvrir quand vous vous
retrouvez par seul chez vous êtes avec
vos parents mais enfin quand même avec
des personnes âgées
il n'y a pas des moments de cafard
difficile jeudi pour le jeune homme
tente où les parents peuvent se remuer
encore à peu près c'est peut-être à
l'avenir en hiver où il ya moins
d'activités
oh non ça va trop grand on fait des
veillées entre camarades alors ça passe
le moment alors on revient toujours de
les contacter jean marc jacot perdre
c'est ça
[Musique]